we are talking about PLL the
perfectionist how are you feeling right
now knowing that the Pretty Little Liars
story is continuing on I'm so excited
it was the challenge for me was was
coming up with the story that paid
homage to the PLO and really honored the
brand of yellow but yet really knew like
a brand new show and brand new stories
and I think we did a pretty good job
pulling that off talk to me about beacon
Heights is very different from Rosewood
feel we shot almost entirely
it's a Warner Brothers backlot show
which most fans already know and this
time it and the show is going to be shot
outside of in and outside of Portland
Oregon it's over we're being true to the
books they take place in the Pacific
Northwest
you can Hyatts and so that's our new
world so of course Sara Shepard had
another book series called the
perfectionist how much you drawing upon
this source material and then kind of
infusing it into this new show well I'm
not gonna be I don't want to spoil
people who have be a spoiler for people
who haven't read the books yet but the
books have a twist to them that would be
kind of possible to pull off in a TV
show so we really just it was great
inspiration for the show but we kind of
go off a little bit sooner than later
I'm like pol would you I mean we're
really seeing my first one yeah so we've
seen a promo teaser for the show so far
I'm completely hooked Ally's moving over
to a new town to kind of start a new
journey a new chapter in her life he
explained a little bit about why she's
moving to this new town well again I
don't want to be a spoiler because we
addressed that in the pilot she had
gonna have a conversation about that and
we understand why she's making this
journey
and it's a personal journey for her
machine there's something she has to
accomplish I think for her own sense of
self nobody'll hear about that right
away in the violent story well naturally
the Emison fans out there are very
worried that Ally is going off on this
journey that emily is not seen into this
promo
should the epicene fans be worried well
it's the the challenge of this spinoff
is is the starting point was who wants
to do it yeah who really wants to be a
part of this new show and you have the
original four of Pretty Little Liars
and we're all ready to go to do new
things that's just sort of the way the
world works and so my challenge then as
the creator of this new show was to
honor the sons relationship and continue
to honor it as we watch this news story
and it's challenge and I hope we've done
the best job possible of honoring what
we know is their truth you're still
close with the PLL's have you talked to
Shay is it a possibility that we could
see Emily on the show I think
everything's possible I think there are
ROG PLL's
are really supportive of the show
they're so supportive of Sasha and
Janelle and me and our new cast and I
think everything is possible
mm-hmm will we see the babies where we
see the twins you will see the twins
yeah yeah that makes it they're a little
older now really toddlers now they're
like maybe three okay so are we getting
a little bit of a time jump almost I
think it's almost a real time time jump
from the time we ended PLL which was a
year ago to the time this show will
premiere it's sort of real time let's
talk about Ali and Mona two of my
favorite characters are gonna get to
interact a lot more how would you
describe their dynamic at the beginning
of the professionist
allison is surprised to see Bonnie you
can see that from the sizzle reel when
she stopped by for pie and it's Mona and
you
really know if you can trust her or not
and that continues to be your her
treatment this is her story
well because the last time we saw Mona
she was playing with her living dolls
Alex and Mary Drake will we get an
answer as to if those girls are still
stuck behind the glass we'll get that
answer in a very cheeky moan away
I love Mona and I loved her because she
was so fierce and she never needed a man
to define her or a woman could we see
her though be in a relationship in this
new show yes I think it's it's it's her
turn as an actress and as a character
for us to have a lot more time to spend
with her and and really get to know Mona
even better than we already do mm-hm
so that sounds like we could get enough
interest for sure can you tease anything
about this person that Mona will be
interacting with I cannot but I know you
will soon but we will okay
okay four weeks in the writers room and
I give you some more information and of
course a few parson coming onto the show
Ava who I know has a lot of Secrets
what type of secrets could she be hiding
what should fans know about her Sophia's
character of Ava has in my opinion my
favorite everybody has a secret going
into this new show and her secret is
really one of my favorites and I don't
want to give up what it is but it's
pretty awesome and pretty cool and she's
kind of a fierce badass yeah yeah
well we in her own way well I was just I
kind of feel so adorable I love the fact
that we had the most badass girls all
coming together how are we gonna see
their dynamic together well he comes in
you know Ali Ali we find out if the
pilot is coming to beacon heights
because she got a job at beacon Heights
University and she is going to she's
going to I mean she's a role model in
some ways for these for these younger
kids so Sophie as a student at beacon
highest and so so Ali yeah too much but
it's me mark it's all good okay
I'm excited about it um we caught up
with Troy in and she said that you guys
have already had conversations about her
possibly directing a future episode is
that something that could happen we'd
love it yes I talked to trying about
that and actually Ashley Benson is
really interested in directing an
episode two
so that would be great figure out all
that stuff that would be amazing good
you're - yeah she's a baller
she's a baller they all are they're all
smart they all could direct if they want
to they all could direct and you've
talked to with the girls they've been so
supportive of the show Lucy told me that
she's so excited that she would be
interested in having Arya kind of maybe
make an appearance and deccan Heights
would you want the OGIS to ever make a
cameo on the show I think it's there's
such a scene with sort of transition to
this new show but it's it's always
possible for people to come in and drop
in looking back at Pretty Little Liars I
personally loved the way that you left
Spencer in Toby's storyline I thought
that it was very true to life and I
thought that it was nice to not have
everything quite so wrapped up with a
bow because that's not how life is but
you did talk to the fans and you did
tell them that you were gonna write a
little bit more you teased that on
Twitter do you have any SPO be updates
for us I kind of know where they are in
my mind and honestly I just haven't had
time to sit down and write that chapter
but but I still go I'll do it can you
give us just men happy I know that great
a little peek into your mind I love that
they're happy
I think it's it's you know they they are
in Philadelphia they're not living in
Rosewood toby is helping to build
housing for the homeless and Spencer is
getting her library for the Pretty
Little Liars fans out there who are
gonna tune into the perfectionist what
do you want them to know before they
watch this first episode well they can
go back and finish for Little Liars
which I think a lot of people are doing
right now I just notice on social media
because of the eight-year birthday or
anniversary note the original airing of
the show yesterday a lot of people seem
to be going back to binge you don't have
to have watch Pretty Little Liars to
enjoy the perfectionist but you'll find
a lot of Easter eggs in the new show if
you do yeah and just
[Music]